a breaking story this hour an israeli
settler has been handed three life
sentences for the murder of three
members
of one palestinian family amiram bell
ben uliel threw a fire bomb into the
home of the
dawab shay family in 2015 killing the
couple and their infant son their
elder son who was four years old at the
time is the only
survivor ben uliel received an addition
of
20 years for the injury of the surviving
child
we have two correspondents on this story
nida ibrahim's in duma in the occupied
west bank at the home where the attack
happened back in 2015 but first to harry
fawcett
who's outside the courtroom in lud so
harry
does this definitely mean life behind
bars
it's three consecutive life sentences
plus
as you say an extra 20 years so yes it
does seem that
barring some extraordinary decision to
pardon
or to give parole which
is all the more unlikely given that the
court also ruled that this was
an ideologically or racially motivated
attack
uh it's almost certain that bernoulli
will serve out the rest of his life
behind bars that is
exactly what the family had asked for
pretty much
down to the letter we've spoken to the
lawyer of the family
and he says that there is also a large
compensatory settlement as well the
maximum
available under israeli law of nearly
300 000
u.s dollars we spoke to the grandfather
of the surviving
young boy ahmed the the father of rihan
the mother
who was killed in that attack he said
that yes this was
the right decision that it would be good
in terms of public opinion and would get
public support
but for him personally and for ahmed it
doesn't bring back
any of the the three family members who
were killed
in that attack and as you say it's an
attack that took place
five years ago it's taken an extremely
long time to get to this point there was
argument about how many attackers may
have been involved
a miner who was also arrested uh was
given a plea bargain
and ruled not to have taken part in the
attack itself
bernoulli his lawyers said that he was
uh
tortured or at least subjected to
enhanced interrogation
by the israeli security services and
there was a separate trial about the
admissibility
of some of his confessions some of which
were ruled out of court
as a result and there's also the
question of the wider issue
of settler violence the israeli security
services said that this was a landmark
case in tackling so-called jewish terror
but there has also been research done
into the
number of attacks that go unpunished uh
one
uh concluding that only eight percent of
people
uh who are suspected of involvement in
these sorts of attacks against
palestinian civilians
actually faced indictment and one
palestinian-israeli
member of the israeli knesset that i
just spoke to said that that was
part of the problem that this was an
exception that this kind of
verdict and this kind of sentence comes
down harry thanks very much harry
fawcett's uh reporting live there from
outside the courthouse in love let's
take it to
duma and al jazeera's correspondent
covering that end
of this developing story ibrahim have we
had a chance to gauge reaction
from the family yet
we went to the house where ahmed lives
now he is the 10 year old the only
survivor of the attack
he actually hasn't went to court today
and refused to attend
any of these sessions over the past few
years
he received the news when he was with
his
grandmothers both of these women each
one of them has lost a child
sad andre hammed both parents of
ahmad who were killed while they were
sleeping in this room alongside their
toddler
the 18 month old ali
the family wants to keep this house as a
museum is kind of a reminder of
settler attacks and actually one of the
grandmothers has told us that
let the settler rot in jail these were
were her words but they wanted us to
know
that nothing will ever compensate the
family
for their loss according to you and
figures settler attacks have been on the
rise for the past
few years just to give you an idea since
the beginning of this
year we're talking about 180 or even
more than 180
attacks by israeli settlers against
palestinians more than
50 of them have caused casualties and
for many palestinians the dhawapshi
trial is a rare issues a rare sentence
and conviction
and they don't believe that the israeli
courts
usually provide justice for the rest of
palestinians
thanks very much ibrahim there reporting
live for the newshour